senator joe manchin kills democratic
dreams of federalizing all elections
and facebook bans donald trump for two
more years i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights
at expressvpn.com we'll get to all the
news
in just one moment first let me remind
you that now would be an excellent
time for you to diversify at least a
little bit in the precious metals i mean
look at what is going on right now we
had an inflation rate
of 4.2 in april alone it's the biggest
bump
since 2008 higher fuel prices higher
food prices construction cost housing
prices
inflation it's not just coming it's
already here if you haven't protected
your savings and your investments you're
making a mistake at the very least you
should diversify a little bit to make
sure the government isn't going to
inflate you
out of your savings so i'm going to tell
you again if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
or 401k into a precious metals high
array go ahead and do it
today text ben 247 4747 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold
i buy my gold from birch gold they have
an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five-star
reviews over ten thousand happy
customers
talk to them have them help you
safeguard your investments ask all of
your questions then take some of your
money
and put it in some precious metals i'm
not saying take all your money
and put in gold bars and bury it in the
backyard i'm saying you need some money
and precious metals in order to hedge
against what is about to happen text ben
247 4747
when you make a purchase before june
30th birch gold will send you a signed
copy of my book how to destroy america
in three easy steps for free
while supplies last again text ben to 47
47 47 protect your savings today text
ben 247
47 47 to get started alrighty so i have
to start today
with a piece of sad sad news that piece
of sad news
is that despite the best attempts of the
daily wires matt walsh
alexander ocasio-cortez's abuelita is
still living
in poverty so you'll recall that last
week
she had her she she tweeted out
alexander ocasio-cortez did
about her grandmother living in puerto
rico and her roof caving in
and then she blamed trump and the policy
making in puerto rico now we could get
into the policy making in puerto rico
who's really responsible for the
distribution of resources in puerto rico
that was kind of democrats in puerto
rico who left
millions of water bottles on the tarmac
to just become completely useless
and all of this but instead one question
that a lot of people were asking
was why exactly is alexander
ocasio-cortez who literally leased a
tesla apparently last month
why is she complaining about the living
conditions of her
grandmother when she could you know help
out her grandmother
and matt walsh was one of the people who
actually tweeted out about this
right so she had tweeted out just over a
week ago my abuela grandmother fell ill
i went to puerto rico to see her
my first time in a year because of covid
this is her home hurricane maria relief
hasn't derived
trump blocked relief dollars for puerto
rico people are being forced to flee
ancestral homes and developers
are taking them okay and this prompted
again some people to say um
alexandra you apparently just you just
leased a 59 000
tesla because you caught got caught in
mid-may
parking in a restricted slot and also
she has this really really nice
apartment like this super nice apartment
she's doing fine right
so matt walsh had tweeted out shameful
that you live in luxury while allowing
your own grandmother to suffer in these
squalid conditions
and then she got mad at him and she
tweeted back in him so matt did what any
generous conservative would do and he
started a gofundme for aoc's grandmother
and he tweeted out as you've heard aoc's
abuela is living in a dilapidated home
that was ravaged by hurricane maria aoc
is unable to help her own grandma for
whatever reason so i have set up this
gofundme campaign to save her home
please give if you can hashtag help
abuela
okay well within hours like four or five
hours
almost 6 000 people had pledged money to
help aoc's grandmother raising over a
hundred
thousand then
the fundraiser was shut down because
somebody presumably from
aoc's office or inside the family
conveyed to go fund me that they weren't
going to take the money
so she then tweeted out my abuela is
okay but instead of only caring for mine
and letting others suffer i'm calling
attention to the systemic injustices you
seem totally fine
with having a in you seem totally fine
with
in having a u.s colony okay
this did result in one of the greatest
headlines of all time okay this is the
headline from the uk independent you
ready
right-wing blogger launches gofundme for
aoc's grandmother in latest personal
attack
no attack quite like trying to hand
somebody a hundred thousand dollars
man now normally they say anti-semitic
attacks they mean somebody getting beat
down the street but i mean if somebody
wants to attack me and nancy's medic
fashion by giving me a hundred thousand
dollars that sounds
kind of okay to me just just terrible
horrifying i can't believe it
so walsh uh then tweeted out someone in
aoc's at wella's family told gofundme
she won't take the money even though aoc
previously claimed her grandmother was
in dire straits and it was trump's fault
aoc still hasn't acknowledged this
effort or thanked us
here's the email from gofundme and then
he provided a screenshot
so uh sad news the the attempt to help
aoc's grandmother was unavailing
um so her grandmother presumably is
still living in the same sort of desire
poverty unless aoc has decided to
redistribute some of her own money
to her grandmother and maybe skip a
tesla payment or two
all right meanwhile the big news of the
weekend is that joe manchin
may have just ended joe biden's
presidency so
joe biden's presidency is deeply reliant
on
two swing senators particularly joe
manchin and kristen cinema
cinema is in arizona which is a purple
state and mansion is in the reddest
state in america
a mansion is a democratic senator from
west virginia he's in aberration
electorally he won his last race
pretty narrowly in west virginia donald
trump won that state by 39 points okay
it's the reddest state in america in
terms of presidential politics
and yet it has this democratic senator
who's really sort of a holdover
from prior generations because west
virginia used to be a reliably
democratic state
for for a very long time it only shifted
red in the last few election cycles
okay so mansion sort of a hold over
there and
because mansion is a democrat the
democrats have the majority
and right now the senate has split 50
50.
the the republicans should have been
able to take one of two seats in georgia
but they failed to take one of the two
seats in georgia
largely because president trump decided
to talk about how georgia and his
elections were all skewed in all this
and republicans in rural areas didn't
show up and vote so you ended up with
two democratic senators in georgia which
is unthinkably stupid and instead you
end up with a democratic majority but
that democratic majority is really
fragile
in the senate and it's particularly
fragile because again joe manchin
knows where his bread is buttered he
knows what state he represents and he is
not going to move along
with this radical biden agenda so joe
biden was for he had basically one of
two choices he was forced into this
choice
choice number one he could pursue a more
moderate agenda that would pick up a few
republican votes plus it would have
cinema
and mansion on board most of the time or
he could run directly to the radical
left and he could try
to apparently leverage mansion and
cinema into doing his bidding
well yesterday it became clear that joe
manchin was not going to allow joe biden
to do the latter
joe biden has been trying it just last
week you'll remember that that joe biden
got up in the middle of a speech and
started ripping on his own senators
he suggested that manchin and cinema
should go along with the killing of the
filibuster
so they could ram through a six trillion
dollar budget
so they could ram through a two trillion
dollar infrastructure package
and hr one which completely federalized
all election procedure
and make it much easier to push ballot
harvesting and voter fraud
and he was going to push cinema and
mansion into the corner over all of this
and manchin and cinema have repeatedly
said over and over and over we are not
no one's going to put baby in a corner
we're not doing this we are not do
and democrats this is it is amazing in
american politics
how voters nationally because every
issue has now been nationalized
the base of the party is out of
alignment with the reality okay the base
of the party of the republican party
will look at senators like susan collins
in maine and we'll go oh she's so
terrible somebody should primary her
neglecting of course that if you primary
susan collins there's a very very good
shot
that the person who replaces who's in
collins is a democrat
meanwhile you have democrats doing the
same thing with mansion and cinema
they're like oh my god look at these
terror
why do we even bother having democrats
in these states good question go for it
seriously primary mansion was somebody
from the aoc wing
primary cinema with somebody from the
aoc wing of the party and see how that
goes for you
those seats will flip republican again
so you could work in line with the
reality
or you just complain about reality and
force the people in your own party
over to the other side of the aisle you
want to have mansion switch parties is a
very very good way to do it
that's how joe manchin is killing joe
biden's progressive dream in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that if you're a responsible human
being you really need to get life
insurance you need to make sure that
your family is taken care of between
father's day flag day national yo-yo day
a lot going on in the month of june
but policy genius makes it easy to cross
life insurance off your to-do list this
busy month so you can get back to the
yoyoing
if someone relies on your financial
support whether we're talking a kid or
an aging parent or even a business
partner
you do need life insurance policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place
why compare well you could save 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius which means
1300 bucks or more per year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies
the licensed experts a policy genius
they work for you they don't work for
the insurance companies so they will
help you out every step of the way
and if you want to get started it's
really simple you go to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
you can compare personalized quotes to
find your best price when you are ready
to apply the policy genius team will
handle the paperwork and the scheduling
for free
policy genius won't sell your
information to other companies policy
genius doesn't add on the extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very important
to get it right okay so there is
something to the strategy that
is pushed by the radical progressive
democrats if they believe that their
agenda's actually
politically popular right and that is
okay fine so we lose the seats in west
virginia and we lose the seats in
arizona but
our agenda is so popular nationwide that
we're going to pick up seats in a bunch
of other places
but here's the problem their agenda is
not that popular which means they're
relying on this bare-bones majority
to push through a bunch of progressive
policies and that barebones majority is
not going to hold and joe manchin made
that clear over the weekend when he
wrote
for the west virginia gazette mail that
he was not going to vote in favor of h.r
which is this bull crap for the people
act so the fourth people act
again is a wild federalization while
voting procedure violates the
constitution
it sucks up all local voting procedure
into the federal level
and then bars state from for example
pushing voter id it bars states from
preventing ballot harvesting which i
think is the most egregious
voting practice in america this is the
practice where you're allowed to go door
to door and pick up people's ballots
from them
you want to talk about the possibility
of voter fraud how about you pay
somebody to go pick up democratic votes
i mean that that is about as as easy a
voter fraud mechanism as exists in
america today and it wouldn't take very
much right
all you'd have to do is go to somebody's
house he's a member of your own party
you knock on the door you say did you
get your absentee ball in the mail they
say yeah sure and
you say well did you fill it out i said
not really you said would you like me to
help you with that
right that like the possibilities for
voter fraud and voter intimidation and
pressure
are nearly endless and democrats were
trying to federalize that entire
procedure they're making voting
significantly less certain right
it's not about broadening the capacity
to vote everybody has the capacity to
vote right now we just had an election
in which 155 million people voted
the the turnout in minority communities
remains extremely high
and yet democrats it's so funny
democrats keep saying look at these
republicans with their
with their voter integrity bills they're
only doing this because trump is whining
about voter fraud and all of this
yeah well here's the thing your guy just
won purportedly by seven million votes
right joe biden won by seven million
votes in the popular vote not
purportedly he actually won by seven
million votes
in the popular vote and you are
complaining that there is voter
suppression going on
how explain and on the basis of that
they're going to violate the
constitution
and federalize all voting procedures
okay so joe manchin is like we're not
doing this he
he writes the right to vote is
fundamental to our american democracy
and protecting that right should not be
about party or politics least of all
protecting this right which is a value i
share should never be done in a partisan
manner
during my time as west virginia
secretary of state i was determined to
protect this right and ensure our
elections are fair accessible and secure
not to benefit my party but all the
people of west virginia for example as
secretary of state
i took specific actions to establish
early voting for the first time in west
virginia
in order to provide expanded options for
those whose work or family schedule
made it difficult to vote on election
day throughout my tenure in politics
i've been guided by the simple
philosophy our party labels can't
prevent us from doing what is right
unfortunately we are now witnessing that
the fundamental rights vote has itself
become overtly politicized
today's debate about how to best protect
our right to vote and hold elections is
not about finding common ground but
seeking partisan advantage
whether it is state laws that seek to
needlessly restrict voting or
politicians who ignore the need to
secure our elections
partisan policy making won't instill
confidence in our democracy it will
destroy it
as such congressional action on federal
voting rights legislation
must be the result of both democrats and
republicans coming together to find a
pathway forward or
we risk further dividing and destroying
the republic we sort of protect and
defend
as elected officials democrats and in
congress have proposed a sweeping
election reform bill called the for the
people act
this more than 800-page bill has
garnered zero republican votes
why are the very republican senators who
voted to impeach trump because of
actions that led to an attack on our
democracy unwilling to support actions
to strengthen our democracy
are these same senators whom many in my
party applauded for their courage now
threats to the very democracy we seek to
protect
the truth i would argue is that voting
an election reform that is done in a
partisan manner will all but ensure
partisan divisions continue to deepen so
manchester is making a pretty easy point
here he's saying listen
it's not just ted cruz he's not voting
for this or josh halley
susan collins isn't voting for this mitt
romney isn't voting for this
right the most moderate republican
senators are not voting for this
so says joe manchin with that in mind
some democrats have again proposed
eliminating the senate filibuster
they've attempted to demonize the
filibuster and conveniently ignore how
it has been critical to protecting the
rights of democrats
in the past for as a reminder just four
short years ago says mansion
in 2017 when republicans held control of
the white house in congress donald trump
was publicly urging senate republicans
to eliminate the filibuster
then it was senate democrats were
proudly defending the filibuster 33
senate democrats penned a letter
two senators chuck schumer and mitch
mcconnell warning of the perils of
eliminating the filibuster
it has been said by much wiser people
than me that cr that absolute power
corrupts absolutely says mansion well
what i've seen during my time in
washington is that every party in power
will always want to exercise absolute
power absolutely
our founders were wise to see them to
the temptation of absolute power and
built in specific checks and balances to
force compromise that serves to preserve
our fragile democracy
so he says i'm not going to kill the
filibuster just to push forward an act
that is going to garner zero republican
support and he's right about all of this
but this does spell
doom it may be that biden's had his high
water mark in terms of legislative
accomplishments that whatever he was
going to get done he basically got done
already
that that giant stimulus bill which is
not a stimulus built it's actually just
inflating
the the currency right now that's all
that's happening it's just inflating
prices
that that giant quote unquote relief
package may be the biggest thing
that he is able to achieve here now he's
pushing
things like this giant infrastructure
package there's no guarantee that
mansion or cinema are going to vote for
a two trillion dollar infrastructure
package
or kill a filibuster in order to do so
mansion has suggested he's not a fan of
it
there's no guarantee that they're gonna
get certainly a six billion
a six trillion dollar budget through a
congress that has split 50 50 in the
senate
and again instead of biden taking the
clintonian attack and tacking to the
center
biden seems like he wants to double down
on stupid here
and and he sort of boxed himself in
because the sort of rhetoric that they
have used the democrats with regard to
voting
suggests that if they are to if they
cave to cinema and mansion
and provide some sort of compromise bill
that for example shores up voter id
but also broadens early voting that if
they did that
their own base would kill them their own
base would come after them
right they've moved so far out on the
limb with their rhetoric this is all
jim crow kind of stuff that to be seen
complicit in that
is death for their base it's another
caught between a rock and a hard place
sort of the same way the republicans who
were also
nursing a very fragile majority in the
senate and thus weren't able to get a
lot done
but had also promised the world to their
base we're stuck between a rock and a
hard place with their own base now
democrats are experiencing the same
thing
and and people like barack obama are
continuing to push it
right here is barack obama over the
weekend suggesting that republicans are
rigging the game
in terms of voting okay what that
suggests is that mansion and cinema are
the villains
and that they need to somehow be held to
account well good luck with that gang
this really has to do with the basic
rules
by which we all have agreed to to
keep this diverse
multiracial democracy functioning
are we going to stick to those rules are
we going to start rigging the game
in a way that breaks it and and that's
not going to be good for business
uh not to mention uh not good for our uh
our soul okay not good for our soul by
the way uh barack obama talking about
our soul is always a laugh considering
how he corrupted american politics in
order to foster his own power
it's pretty it's pretty astonishing and
when you talk about rigging the rules of
the game recognize that's what hr one is
it is a giant rigging of the rules of
the game
i'm sorry but but massive early voting
is also rigging the rules of the game
because you are rigging in advance how
people are going to vote
okay the the the idea that you are
voting three months in advance of an
election before any of the news is
broken is a bad policy it is a bad idea
dnc chair jamie harrison is very upset
with joe manchin here he was ripping on
his own senator yesterday
i'm very disappointed in senator
manchin's decision
and obviously i disagree because listen
i know he wants to protect democracy but
there will be no democracy if we don't
protect the right
rights to votes of all americans you
know alex there's only one party in this
nation right now that has over 350 plus
bills in order to suppress and encumber
the rights of voters in this
in this nation only one party right now
that is trying to cut
hours in which people can go vote uh
change the the standard by which courts
uh look at elections and determine
whether or not there's fraud in
elections
only one party that is allowing
political goons to go
and try to intimidate voters at the
precinct and that's the republican party
this is not a bold size issue okay so
again he's ripping on his own senator
and basically putting himself in a
position in jamie harrison
where if you don't oppose your own
senator if you don't rip on your own
senator now you're a racist right you're
in league with the evil republicans
now to debunk what he's talking about
here this notion that you are somehow
restricting the right to vote by not
allowing the emergency conditions of the
pandemic
to be the new normal is absurd on its
face
and we had record voting in 2008 we had
very high voting in 2012.
voting fell off in 2016 because people
didn't like either candidate and we had
record voting in 2020.
the notion that people are having their
votes suppressed in the united states is
just a lie there is more evidence of
voter fraud in the united states than
there is evidence of voter suppression
in the united states
there's not a ton of evidence of either
but there's better evidence that voter
fraud is easy and available then that
voter suppression is easy and available
okay democrats keep pushing and keep
pushing this you know keep
keep pumping that dead horse i mean
seriously just keep doing it guys
because you're not
you're alienating your own senators
here's jennifer granholm the energy
secretary ripping on joe manchin for not
supporting the infrastructure package
due respect madam secretary but you
didn't answer my question because the
question is
would manchin vote for a bill if it's
just democrats and you said he would
vote for it if it's bipartisan i mean i
don't know of any republicans who are
willing to vote for this conference
yeah well not just preference that might
be his line though right
right of course that's his line and
you'll have to ask him about where his
ultimate bottom line
is but i know that he sees the faces of
people who need these investments too
okay so she's saying she's not sure if
man look mansion is going to be the
swing vote he always was
the question was whether he's going to
kill the filibuster it's clear he's not
going to this means that democrats
cannot pass any substantive bill
outside of reconciliation reconciliation
is a budget procedure
democrats have already used one of their
they're supposed to have two per year
they already used one on the american
relief
bill okay which again has been a
complete boondoggle
they have one left okay and they're
probably gonna end up using it on
raising corporate taxes we'll get to in
a little while so they're not gonna have
it for infrastructure they're not gonna
have it for hr one
it wasn't applicable to hr one anyway
because it's not a budgetary bill
so democrats are in some trouble here
the obama administration they don't have
a lot of substance left
out there except for raising taxes
that's pretty much it raising taxes and
spending some more
that's that is all that is left of their
agenda they're sort of world-breaking
let's change social policy in the united
states via legislature
via legislative policy that's not on the
table anymore this administration could
have seen its high water mark already
and you know who's saying that
the folks at the new york times quote
democrats defeated president donald j
trump and captured the senate last year
with a racially diverse coalition that
delivered victories by tiny margins in
key states like georgia
arizona and wisconsin in the next
election they cannot count on repeating
that feat a new report warns a review of
the 2020 election conducted by several
prominent democratic advocacy groups has
concluded the party is at risk of losing
ground with black hispanic and
asian american voters unless it does a
better job of presenting an economic
agenda encountering republican efforts
to spread
misinformation and tie all democratic
candidates to the far left by the way
tie all democratic candidates to the far
left we don't have to tie anything
you guys are doing it yourselves you're
attacking your own moderate senators
you have the president of the united
states attacking the two moderate
senators in your coalition i don't have
to do anything i don't even have to say
anything
all i have to do is stand here and point
like donald sutherland at the end of
invasion of the body snatchers i just
point at you that's it
republicans don't have to spread
misinformation all they have to do is
spread information
the 73-page report obtained by the new
york times was assembled at the behest
of third way a centrist think tank and
the collective pack and latino victory
fund which promote black and hispanic
candidates
the document is all the more striking
because it is addressed to the
victorious party
in part the study found democrats fell
short of their aspirations because many
house and senate candidates
failed to match joe biden's support with
voters of color those constituencies
include hispanic voters in florida and
texas vietnamese
vietnamese american and
filipino-american voters in california
and black voters in north carolina you
know why
because you keep going wild to the left
you keep going wild to the left
and yet the democrats have shown no
appetite to move back to the center
we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the best clothing on the market
i'm talking of course about cuts
clothing okay i will
admit to you freely i when i get some
nice clothes
i tend to get like a lot of that piece
of nice clothing and then just wear that
all the time
cut is the only t-shirt i will wear it
is that good the sport of business means
demanding excellence from your craft and
wardrobe
your fits need to be versatile blending
timeless style and comfort so you look
as good as you feel for that
there's cuts clothing cuts has taken a
classic men's fashion staple the plain
tee they've refined it combining premium
quality with a minimalist aesthetic
cuts shirts polos hoodies and crew
sweatshirts are made for the man who
works hard plays hard and never settles
for less
all in the sport of business take a
plain team and make it tony stark
the bleeding edge of fabric technology
meets the man confident enough to wear
it cut
clothing it is the perfect t-shirt and
they also have the new cut hoodie
they've developed hyperloop french terry
fabric it's a texture that's temperature
controlled and ageless
or try the wrinkle free pica polo a
design that keeps you fitted for the
office golf course at home the gym
or your next hot date cuts is premium
with a purpose i'm telling you this
clothes
they really are amazing like i only wear
cuts polos i really only wear cuts
t-shirts
they're just that good it's not just a
lifestyle it's not just clothing it is
office leisure apparel for the sport of
business get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
shapiro that is cutsclothing.com shapiro
for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing
cutsclothing.com
shapiro okay so meanwhile the biden
administration continues to push forward
extraordinarily radical plans
particularly when it comes to economics
now what they are doing internationally
is attempting to push all other
countries
into setting a sort of floor so that we
can move above the floor so
joe biden knows full well that his
garbage
tax policy like he's pushing corporate
taxes up to 28
now he knows that if he gets that done
every corporation in america that has
the capacity to do so will think about
offshoring
they'll think about reorganizing outside
the united states of america
right because this happened a lot during
the obama administration there's a
tremendous acceleration
during the obama administration because
you just reorganize
in another western european country so
biden has decided to combine
with all of the progressive left
politicians in europe
in order to foster a corporate baseline
tax rate
now the only reason that these other
countries would do that
is presumably because they think that
they will still have some sort of
advantage over biden
i understand that if if they set the
international
baseline corporate tax rate at 15
percent and mine goes to 28 he's still
almost doubling it
so what they're figuring is okay well
this is still pretty good collective
action for us
because if we all go to 15 and i'm
germany and i can get france to do that
well then i i guess people won't shift
their corporate headquarters to france
as opposed to germany
so we'll use biden leveraging us as a
way to still continue to have an
advantage over the united states
but we'll get credit from biden and will
prevent all the other european countries
from apparently basically gaming the
system
but joe biden meanwhile is making it
harder to do business everywhere
he's trying to leverage by the way there
are a lot of other countries on planet
earth
you're about to see if any country is
smart
out there that is outside of the g7
they're immediately
going to lower their corporate tax rate
to almost zero and everyone will
immediately start to reorganize in that
country
according to cnn the group of seven
finance ministers gathering in london
agreed saturday to back a global minimum
tax of at least 15 percent on
multinational companies
the g7 group also agreed the biggest
company should pay tax where they
generate sales
not just where they have a physical
presence so in other words if a french
company sells product in the united
states they'll have to
pay the united states tax right this is
going to lead to all sorts of serious
complications by the way
because again how do you even get i mean
now you're gauging it from from point of
sale
so you have to determine whether you
think that you're gonna make more money
by exporting to the united states or not
exporting
it's it's a de facto tariff because
eventually what you're gonna end up with
is if the united states has a higher tax
rate on these corporations
than does france for example then
companies are just going to
stop exporting to the united states as
much they're going to look for other
markets emerging markets
meanwhile that is a domestic boon for
american companies presumably it's basic
it's a de facto tariff
it makes it much harder for consumers to
get products that they want to get at
the prices they want to get them in the
united states
taxpayers end up paying the price on all
of this uk finance minister rishi sunak
announced the agreement in a video
posted on twitter saturday saying the g7
finance ministers hailing from canada
france germany italy japan
the uk and the united states had reached
a historic agreement to reform the
global tax system to make it fit for the
global digital age and crucially to make
sure it's fair so the right companies
pay the right tax in the right places
okay right there is a defined as
progressives get to tell you what to do
the agreement was made during a g7
meeting of finance ministers in london
attended by janet yellen yellen said
saturday the agreement was a significant
unprecedented commitment from the
world's richest economies aimed at
preventing companies from avoiding taxes
by shifting
profits overseas because again by the
way corporate profits that's double
taxation because all that
stuff gets passed down to you in the
form of dividends or in the form
of wealth that is passed on
generationally or in the form of income
right because most of us work for
corporations
tech giants such as apple facebook and
google might be affected by the
agreement foreign governments have long
complained
large digital companies should pay them
more in taxes some have recently passed
taxes
specifically for targeting revenue
generated by such companies including
those based in the united states
like facebook google and amazon
nick clegg of course or facebook whose
main job is to please the biden
administration said they're happy about
this this is what
people don't understand about these
major corporations they understand that
facebook
over at facebook nick clegg understands
facebook will survive the global
taxation
it is the smaller competitors who are
going to pay the price
we now live under the rule of
corporatism cronyism right in which
these giant corporations work hand in
glove
with the government in order to enshrine
their own power and if they have to pay
a little bit more in tax to make sure
their competitors can never rise up they
do it
google said it strongly supported the
work done to update international tax
rules and hopes countries continue to
work together to ensure a balanced and
durable agreement will be finalized
soon said google spokesperson jose
castaneda
a spokesperson for amazon also embraced
all of this
okay so again they're they're a
there are a couple of countries that
want to undercut this ireland is one of
them
because they offer a corporate tax rate
of just 12.5 percent this is what smart
countries will do if you're not a member
of the g7 lower your corporate taxes now
and get ready for the money to flow in
all of this is not going to be good for
the united states economy raising taxes
sucks money
out of the entrepreneurial sector and
into the pockets of giant government
bureaucrats who then spend the money on
stupid garbage which is why you have low
growth rates across the west for the
last several decades
okay but but joe biden is delusional he
said our plan is working
except it's not here is joe biden having
to announce last friday that his
economic plan is working despite the
fact that
again we had a third straight month of
under
performance economically speaking right
we had march which was a big job month
and then was revised downwards like 900
thousand jobs revised downwards to 770
000 jobs
then we had april which missed by three
quarters of a million jobs
and then we had may which must buy a
hundred thousand jobs
and this is again because joe biden's
economic policy is garbage and yet here
was joe biden
stumbling and bumbling his way via his
war with the teleprompter
to the notion that his plan is working
we have a chance to seize on the
economic momentum
of the first months of my administration
not just to build back but to build back
better this much is already clear
we're on the right track that is not
clear the plan is working
nope and we're not going to let up now
nope we're going to continue to move on
okay so even the the folks of the
washington post were just cheerleading
him they said you know what
maybe we'll get back to where we were in
terms of jobs by the end of 2022.
now you may have noted that it is now
june of 2021.
that's insane his plans are not working
he's gone back to the same slow growth
strategies that were pursued by barack
obama hamstring major corporations
threaten them with with post-facto
taxation
threaten them with global taxation raise
the spending
i mean the these economic plans are not
in fact working he's taking credit for a
natural economic boom
that he himself is suppressing
it's it's amazing to watch the gas
lighting right joe biden said that
we are experiencing historic jobs
progress
okay no we're experiencing historic jobs
progress because we had the economy put
into an artificial coma for a year
there's an induced coma for a year and
now we're coming out of that you don't
get to take credit for us coming out of
that when you are doing your best to
make sure we never come out of it
this is progress historic progress
progress that's pulling our economy
out of the worst crisis it's been in 100
years
and it's testament to the new strategy
this is growing our this economy
not only growing up but going from the
bottom up and the middle out
remember when i took office in january
our economy wasn't a tailspin
job growth had stalled covid was raging
average initial claims for unemployment
insurance were over 830
000 per week now those claims have
fallen below 430
000. about half of what they were when i
took office we had a reduction in the
labor force participation rate in the
united states when he says bill back
better how about this how about we just
build back to where we were before
all this stuff happened you know 3.6
unemployment rate and rising wages how
about that
build that better it's just it's all an
excuse for them to push bad policy
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
you don't want to be going to the auto
parts store now or ever why would you
want to you stand in line you finally
get to the front of the line they ask
you a bunch of questions you have to
look it up on your phone
finally you get the answers and they're
like oh yeah let me check the back they
come back out don't have the part we're
ordering it online and we're up charging
you by 35
or you could just go to the interwebs
and skip the middleman
rockauto.com is so much easier than
doing any of that stuff
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
their prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts their family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate and quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you again
rockauto.com go check them out right now
that's rockauto.com
you'll get the lowest available price
and you'll get the best available part
rockguard.com right you appear on there
how did you hear about usbox so they
know that we sent you in the first place
okay so meanwhile joe biden's labor
secretary is just fibbing
so his labor secretary marty walsh he
says you know what
it's not that we're paying people to
stay home that's keeping people home
it's um
it's also it's it's it's actually you
know like um well
that's pretty much their answer over at
the biden administration here we go
president biden's plan is was working
we're going to continue to move forward
here
we saw growth in hospitality and leisure
and restaurants the largest growth for
the last two months
and that's a good thing a lot of the a
lot of the restaurants and businesses
were that were
saying that people weren't coming back
to work because of the 300
are actually in those industries and
we're seeing those industries coming
back which is a great thing to do
for our country to see those industries
coming back seeing hospitality come back
seeing travel come back
it's great to see that okay um yeah
except for the fact that people aren't
coming back and people are having to
incentivize people to even come in for
interviews
you know who's admitting this much by
the way new jersey governor phil murphy
and new jersey governor phil murphy is a
terrible governor he also is a radical
democrat
he's one of these shutdown insane
governors who decided that every single
thing in his state would need to be shut
down
until basically forever he he fully
admits that
payments are keeping people at home i
think it's a combination of things
stephanie i think it's
uh more time on the clock i do uh
support jason's comments that this is
temporary to some degree perhaps it's
due to that
somewhat to the 300 premium i think that
may be part of it but i i
actually believe it's a combination of
things
i think it may be day care we're not
entirely full on in school
so you've got some realities of taking
care of your kids
i think you've got folks who are scared
still to get back into an indoor
setting okay nope we have all of the
same provisions that we had before the
pandemic
right we have the same exact daycare
centers that are now open they were open
before the pandemic and yet
you're sugg like at least they're
acknowledging the reality here's one
area where he won't acknowledge the
reality right there's the there's the
reality that democrats know about and
then there's the ign
the reality they will acknowledge the
reality that they know about is that
when they raise taxes and make it harder
to do business
businesses don't do business and then
there's the reality they will
acknowledge which is
maybe sometimes that's true but we're
going to pretend it's other things so
here was new jersey governor murphy
saying people aren't leaving new jersey
because of high taxes
of course they are i know people who
have left new jersey because of high
taxes
i left california because of high taxes
here is here's phil murphy
saying a perfectly idiotic thing it
turns out people in fact are not leaving
new jersey the census uh
showed that we gained uh many hundreds
of thousands over the last decade and in
the past year alone
somewhat due to the pandemic by the way
a lot more people are coming than
leaving
that does not mean that we don't care
about cost of living
or the price you pay to live in a in a
state that we think is the number one
state in america
to raise a family uh i would just say
when you're the densest state in the
nation which we are in the densest
region
in the nation uh in the northeast
corridor
with a more than our share of legacy
assets any infrastructure program
uh we are a huge winner okay nope
okay democrats again refusing to
acknowledge the reality so fine keep
keep it up guys don't acknowledge the
realities
keep pushing radical spending and
taxation policy keep pushing
more of this critical race theory
nonsense that you guys have been pushing
and see how it works out for you
seriously and alienate the two moderate
senators in your coalition at the same
time
it's gonna go great now the good news
for the democrats is they can always
count
on the love of the media so brian
stelter had on gensake over the weekend
cnn's reliable sources and he could ask
her anything right anything
i mean right now the white house has
been promoting misinformation about the
economy
the white house has been promulgating
this information about covid the white
house has been lying
about the role of china and they've been
prevaricating about what they plan to do
with regard to china
you could ask you know about all or any
of those things instead here's how the
media
like this is just such a window into how
the the cnn media
treat the their their bosses over the
democratic party because let's be frank
about this they're a propaganda wing for
the white house
here is brian stelter performing his uh
his lap dog functions
busy summer ahead infrastructure
election reform
what does the press get wrong when
covering
biden's agenda when you watch the news
when you read the news
what do you think we get wrong
um what do you think we get wrong what
what how is it
can you imagine him asking that to
kaylee mcinnady what do you think we get
wrong about trump
he would never ask that question come on
we all know what this is
how cozy are the press with with the
white house at this point so the white
house reporter for usa today tweeted
this
out yesterday tweeted out a picture of
cookies that kamala harris was handing
out
two members of the white house press
corps on air force two
their picture i don't know who did this
cookie and
i maybe they're good at cookie making
but it's a
kamala harris handed out cookies with an
icing picture of kamala harris
on the cookie but her face is not on the
cookie
it looks it's like completely it's it's
completely mushed out
so she just
looks like one of these modern paintings
in you know in italy every so often
you'll get the city will will find some
local artists to redo like a classic
renaissance work of art and then it'll
look completely deformed it's like the
ronaldo statue that i love so much
where the face looks nothing like it so
that those are the kind of cookies that
kamala harris is handing out and the
members of the press just eating it up
tomorrow is the greatest
joe biden's the greatest what kind of
ice cream you're eating today joe
yeah by the way the people tend to think
that the media are helping the democrats
in this there comes a point where
the help begins to hurt because you're
not asking them any of the tough
questions they require in order to
correct policy
so instead of a popular clintonian
presidency you're going to end up with a
very very unpopular
jimmy carter presidency because you
spend all of your time ass-kissing the
people who are promulgating bad policy
okay in just one second
we're going to be getting to covet
policy over at the white house and the
continuing fibs
and sillinesses with regard to anthony
fauci first
let's talk about the fact that you need
to upgrade your employee base you need
to make your employees better
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you'll probably face a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find the needle in a haystack sure
you could post your job to some job
board then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along that's why
you should try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with just one click then
ziprecruiter's matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply in fact
zipper career is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter
get a quality candidate within the very
first day it's no wonder
over 2.3 million businesses have come to
zip recruiter for their hiring needs
i mean without zip recruiter we would
not have the wonderful fabiola
who not only does an incredible job with
makeup but also
apparently i did not know this can
breakdowns also is an archer
and she's not great at coming and like
walking down hills i've seen her fall
down a hill but
she's great in terms of recovery like
very very tough so while other companies
overwhelm you with way too many options
zipper crew refines you what you're
looking for the needle
in the haystack right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this web
address
zippercareer.com dailywire once again
remember to go to this
uniqueplaceziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-re zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest
way to hire all right we're going to get
to more in a second first we all love
watching candace drop truth bombs here
at daily wire but we are also huge fans
of letting the truth trickle through our
headphones on the go
that's why we've made sure that one of
her best qualities logic can go
wherever you go as well whether she's
asking donald trump hard-hitting
questions like whether she should hop on
his ticket in 2024 or getting adam
carolla to expose hollywood
conservatives or giving feminism the
roast it deserves with her panel of
guests you're guaranteed a smart
funny listening experience so subscribe
to and download candace the audio
podcast on apple spotify
or whatever your platform of choice may
be if you like what you hear be sure to
leave a five star review keep candace's
podcast at the top
of the charts while you're at it don't
stop at candace my new series debunked
has an audio episode dropping every
saturday in it
i expose leftists for the frauds they
are and their ideology for the silliness
it is in only 15 minutes or less so
if you're stepping out for a quick walk
learn how to absolutely destroy
the left's talking points surrounding
teachers unions or transgender rights
ideology
or the minimum wage with every step you
take don't let the woke roll over you
with their baseless accusations
and silly lies about science listen to
debunked prepare yourself for the many
unfortunate leftist encounters you may
have on a daily basis
just head on over to apple spotify
wherever you listen to your podcast
subscribe and download
debunked your future self will thank you
if you like what you hear leave a five
star review bump this podcast to the top
of the charts
again it's a separate podcast called
debunked search for it subscribe
leave a five star view left hates it
when we succeed so that's always a
double win you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now meanwhile the biden administration
continues to defend the embattled dr
anthony fauci is in battle because we've
seen his emails over the last year and
it turns out that he's a
career bureaucrat who defends his
institution above the science we've
known this for a while
he has shifted his opinion on everything
based not on the science
based instead on whatever the biden
administration wants
from him or what is considered the most
protective viewpoint with regard to the
nia id that's the institution for which
he works nonetheless the biden
administration suggests there are no
circumstances under which they would
fire anthony fauci which is
a hell of a job guarantee i wouldn't
provide that here no circumstances like
at all
like he's caught infla granted elected
with a horse and nothing
like it turns out to be personally
cooked up well i i
i could imagine circumstances like why
would you ever say something like this
seriously here's jen sackey
coming out four square with dr anthony
fauci
dr fauci is a renowned public servant a
civil servant i should say career civil
servant
uh he's overseen management of multiple
global health crises and the attacks
and and attacks launched on him are
certainly something
we wouldn't stand by since you mentioned
dr thought you again can you imagine any
circumstance where
president biden would ever fire him no
no under any circumstances okay like
what if what if
for example he knew full well about the
fact that the united states had funneled
funding
via a third party eco-health alliance to
the wuhan lab where covet 19 was
developed and then he had actively
played down the possibility of a lab
leak
for like a year what what if that well
like
that might be a problem would it not
apparently not joe biden says he's still
confident in fouchy now to be fair
joe biden doesn't know where he is or
who anthony fauci is so uh you always
have to take this stuff with a grain of
salt he's about to walk into a wall here
mr president you saw
yes i'm very confident
he popped his head back out just to say
that it's like a weird groundhog
and meanwhile i'm not sure why they're
so confident in dr fauci dr fauci has
suddenly become very hawkish
on asking china to be compliant with his
request for information
he said over the weekend that he would
love to see what happened
in china in 2019 he said i would like to
see the medical records of the three
people who are reported to have got sick
in 2019 did they really get sick and if
so
what did they get sick with the same
with the miners who got ill years ago
what are the medical records of those
people say
it's entirely conceivable the origins of
sars covey two was in that cave
and either started spreading naturally
or went through the lab
oh is that conceivable now interesting
fascinating
like you spent a year downplaying this
thing and saying anybody who mentioned
it was ridiculous
that was shortly after you were asked
specifically by rand paul
in public whether you're participating
in masks theater no i would never
participate and then it turns out of
course you were participating in mask
theater
you're also asked by rand paul once
you've had covet aren't you immune and
you're like no
we don't know he said you're really
really bad at your job
but the good news is the administration
is going to defend you because at least
you're not pro-trump and that's the
important thing meanwhile anthony fauci
appearing on media only friendly media
of course and being asked questions like
why are people so mean to you on msnbc
you know there's this concern is it a
natural evolution
or is it something that happened out of
a lab an accident or wedding but what
have you
it is important to understand that but
it is being approached now in
in a very vehement way in in a very
distorted way i believe by attacking
me i think that the question is
extremely
legitimate you should want to know how
this
happened so that we can make sure it
doesn't happen again
but what's happened in the middle of all
that i've become the object of
extraordinary
i believe completely inappropriate
distorted
uh misleading and misrepresented attacks
really have you now interesting
some of us were actually willing to give
dr patrick the benefit of doubt for like
months and months and months got a lot
of flack for that
because people wanted to jump to a
conclusion and then i reached the
conclusion that many of them wanted
which is that he's not a good public
servant
and uh and now i guess i'm the source of
these distorted attacks like what have i
said about voucher that's a distortion
can anyone name a thing there's an
article in politico that suggested that
i was at the forefront of leading the
attacks on foundry what have i said
about him that's untrue
seriously like name the thing i've said
about voucher that's untrue you can't
because i have not i've said far fewer
untrue things than dr fauci has
that's for damn sure j bhattacharya over
at stanford university
who was widely reviled among democrats
for the last year
because he had the temerity to suggest
that perhaps we ought to aim for hurt
immunity among the young
and healthy or that perhaps we ought to
lower restrictions among the young and
healthy while protecting the elderly
which is exactly what ron desantis did
in florida it's a great success
bhattacharya went hard after fouchy over
the weekend
he's been all over the place on masks uh
there's some emails
you can find in the treasure trove of
emails have been released where he
acknowledges that the the virus is
aerosolized
well the the cloth mask that the people
in recommending they're not very
particularly effective
against aerosolized neoviruses i i don't
really understand
uh his back and forth and his answer
made absolutely no sense yeah you should
change your mind when the science
changes
but what is that science that changed
that convinced him that mass are
the most effective way uh in fact like
the remember the cdc director
uh robert redfield said the mass were
more effective than than vaccines and dr
fauci did not contradict him when when
dr scott atlas
said that that was nonsense which it was
i mean i think he's
it's just it i think his credibility is
entirely shot okay and that is true his
credibility is shot but here is the
thing
for a year if you contradicted vouching
in any way
or the who or to science right
scientific institutions not the process
of science
if you did that you'd be shut down by
facebook misinformation
misinformation this is why you wonder
why so many conservatives are upset
about social media and their crackdown
on particular types of information
not because we believe that everything
you're cracking down on is true and
decent
it's because we don't trust you to
determine what is true and decent we do
not think
you should be the arbiter of truth so
for example facebook is now announcing
that they have banned trump for an
additional two years
according to the new york times facebook
said on friday trump's suspension from
the service would last at least two more
years
keeping the former president off
mainstream social media for the 2022
midterm elections as the company also
said it would end a policy of treating
posts
from politicians differently from those
of other users the social network said
trump would be eligible for
reinstatement in january 2023 before the
next
presidential election okay now
regardless of what you feel
about trump regardless of what you feel
about what he said about the election
the notion that facebook should be
deciding what you are allowed to see and
hear
is completely absurd it's absurd
especially considering that for the last
year
if you said true things about the
possibility of a lab leak from wuhan
you are going to be suppressed on social
media the question isn't about trump
specifically the question is about what
standards do you guys have and the
answer is you don't have any standards
other than the arbitrariness of bouncing
from wall to wall
along with what other whatever democrats
would like today if democrats want you
to support a global tax you'll do it if
democrats want you to ban trump you'll
do it and if democrats want you
to uphold the scientific credibility of
people who have lost all credibility
like fouchy you'll do that too
so we don't trust you nor should we
already we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
moles show he discusses joe biden
ignoring d-day to remember the tulsa
race riot of 1921. you can hear more
details about that story
on michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sci events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a lecturer at yale fantasizes about
shooting white people
joe biden ignores d-day to remember the
tulsa race riot of 1921
and facebook bans trump for another two
years check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]